token Optimist turned mincemeat courtesy
of a particularly bloodthirsty vampire
bat Glenn was a Walking Dead favorite so
come time for him to bite the dust why
was Actor Stephen Yoon so down to say
adios to his adored character
dumbass sweating scared and hopeless
Rick Grimes is stuck in a tank
surrounded by walkers on all sides in
the series premiere of The Walking Dead
he's not stupid he knows he's finished
until a voice comes in over the radio
you in the tank
cozy in there before we learn who's
behind the voice the camera zooms out
over the city of Atlanta and the episode
ends episode 2 however wastes no time
introducing this mysterious new
character to us Glenn ree played by
Steven Yoon Glenn became a fan favorite
over the course of the show reminding
viewers that there's light even in the
darkest of times The Walking Dead itself
however doesn't play favorites and Glenn
meets his fate in the form of negan's
bat Lucille at the beginning of season
seven Yoon had no choice but to leave
after that seeing as Glenn's demise was
more than definitive however there's
more to his departure than just his
character's untimely death Steven Yoon
spoke with fellow thespian Riz Ahmed for
varieties actors on actors and naturally
The Walking Dead came up being part of a
series that big doesn't just vanish from
the public Consciousness when an actor
moves on to different projects after all
especially when they play a character as
beloved as Glenn it's an extremely
special role to Yoon but he also openly
admitted that he didn't mind leaving the
character behind Glenn is a Plucky nice
guy nice to everybody Yoon said and
while he enjoys expressing that part of
himself as an actor he was only able to
do it for so long before it got to him
Yoon said there was a point in which I
realized that he almost became a ceiling
because I became an idea over a human
character from his perspective that
limited where he was able to go as an
actor and being or feeling boxed in is
the last thing any actor wants it was
time to move on
when the actors decided to kill Glenn
off Yoon says there really wasn't much
of a fight on my end he added however
that it was still sad regardless since
departing from post-apocalyptic Georgia
Yoon has made the most of his time
appearing in critically acclaimed
projects like sorry to bother you
burning and manari Productions that
allowed him to explore roles other than
the genial natured guy fans will always
remember in Miss Yoon as Glenn but it's
a wonderful thing that he's been able to
expand his body of work elsewhere in the
years since his Walking Dead goodbye
Steven Yoon has taken up some remarkable
acting opportunities he's expanded his
filmography while trying out roles that
not too long ago he likely wouldn't have
had a chance at Landing nevertheless in
the eyes of many he'll always be the man
behind Glenn ree with that in mind as
The Walking Dead franchise expands in
all directions could we see Yoon return
to the role of Glenn in some form or
fashion during a July 2022 appearance on
the Conan O'Brien needs a friend podcast
Yoon made it abundantly clear that the
end of his Walking Dead tenure was
indeed the end he told O'Brien the
police voice in my head said if you do
it again you're a hack so I don't do it
again I cringe at the thought this
confirmed without a shadow of a doubt
that he's done with the Glenn roll from
here on out continuing Yoon added
there's not like a crack in the door it
is slammed shut and barricaded
even though it would be cool to see
glenry in The Walking Dead Universe one
more time don't get your hopes up that
it'll happen if his comments and career
trajectory prove anything it's that
Steven Yoon has left TWD and his iconic
character in the past
foreign